welcome to the wack gamers yeah we're
gonna follow up our fall 2010 best games
video with a new video yes we thought
we'd focus on the games we don't really
want to buy the worst of the worst
coming out this fall and these aren't
fake these are real real real quick
couple of you mentioned Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood and call of duty black oops
Black Ops black goop's I just like black
ooze black ops coming out yes we are
sort of looking forward to them but we
just want to mention them because people
are harassing okay no they exist back
the terrible games terrible games
first up Deadliest Catch sea of chaos I
thought we were talking about bad games
are you [ __ ] serious
this is it that looks pretty good to me
you know it's not a stripper game where
you get crabs oh no you're on the low
yeah yeah this is the game where you
just pull in the tanks of crabs and then
offload them on and then at the end of
it the captain dies but but it's all to
a Bon Jovi soundtrack oh yeah i'ma catch
crabs yeah yeah that's kind of lost its
luster
yeah how many how many people you think
fall in the water yeah at least five
which is what gives the California rolls
the extra flavor which is so good you
can taste the death next game Karaoke
Revolution gali Edition that sounds
awful it's the game where you karaoke to
a show about a club that does karaoke
you it sounds like a game that my
girlfriend would force me to play
everyone to sing really bad covers of
songs that you used to like and and
don't anymore for good reason now you
can oh my goodness I don't care how much
you like Lee but just go buy those songs
in Karaoke Revolution I actually care
how much you like Lee I'm not shouldn't
not gonna pass value judgement no I'm
going to is it supposed to be funny I
don't get it I love that show anyway ow
next up Zumba Fitness it Zumba Fitness I
don't know can we stop making games
about being fit I'm playing video games
to ignore the fact that I'm fat yeah and
if I wanted to play a fitness game I
would play Wii Fit not I'm not a game
that requires the PlayStation Move
controller because nothing looks lamer
than doing aerobics with a lit wand he's
got a point that's what she said so I
would have to say probably the worst one
that's coming out is Yogi Bear the video
game
yeah yeah little late on the mark they
wanted to be clear that it wasn't the
cartoon it is Yogi Bear the video game
video game which I you know it's it's a
poignant time I wanted a video game
about a bear who is really based off of
the neighbor on The Honeymooners because
that's something kids can relate to
today it is that and the love of picnic
baskets and you know national parks
which we've also managed to get rid of
since Yogi Bear this it wasn't but is
there any reason to play this there's no
reason to make there totally is Yogi
Bear anyway those are our picks for the
worst games coming out this fall come on
Adam so yogi baby say goodbye to the
people
I'm by later don't buy those games and
don't forget to subscribe
here's a link no it's right on your face
put your face this point in it yes
subscribe right there right here and
then check out our other videos they'll
be in the post role or whatever they
call it